استاذنكم سيدي جلاله الملك للبدء بمراسم
عقد القران الميمون
سعاده الشيخ من فضلك تطلعنا سمو الامير
حسين وتخاطبه قائلا
زوجتك زوجتك ابنتي رجوه ابنه رجوه على
كتاب الله على كتاب الله وعلى سنه رسوله
وعلى سنه رسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى
الله عليه وسلم وعلى المهر وعلى المهر
المسمى بيننا المسمى بيننا سيدي سمو
الامير
لو خاطبت سعاده الشيخ قائلا وانا وانا
قبلت الزواج قبلت الزواج منها منها لنفسي
لنفسي على كتاب الله على كتاب الله وسنه
رسوله وسنه رسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى
الله عليه وسلم وعلى المهر وعلى المهر
المسمى بين المسمى بيننا مبارك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين وصلى الله على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم بارك لهما وبارك
عليهما واجمع بينهما في خير بكرامه سوره
الفاتحه
[موسيقى]
بامكانكم سيدة
[تصفيق]
مبارك سيدنا